so Donald Trump Kid Rock Tucker Carlson
Dana White all come out at UFC at
Madison Square Garden and the whole
Arena erupts in cheering this is massive
Democrats know Joe Biden can't win his
polls are in the gutter Trump is winning
in Aggregate and when Donald Trump has
New York City cheering for him and
Tucker Carlson and Kid Rock it uh
doesn't paint a very good picture for uh
the Democrats however Gavin Newsome is
probably going to be there in the hole
and at some point he's going to announce
he's taking over V ramaswami masterfully
calling them out saying we know he's
running a shadow campaign we know
Biden's not going to be the guy so we
got news out of California Gavin Nome is
admitting that they only cleaned up the
homeless problem because xinping was
coming and uh this is a big scandal